[موسيقى]
ونحييكم من جديد دخلت الحرب في السودان
بين حليفي الامس اي الجيش والدعم السريع
دخلت شهرها ثاني دون التوصل الى اتفاق
النهائي لاطلاق النار فالاسبوع الخامس على
التوالي تتواصلوا فيه المعارك الدميه
ويتجدد القصف والانفجارات في مناطق متفرقه
من العاصمه الخرطوم وكذلك في الولايات رغم
اتفاق الطرفين على اتفاق مبادئ جده
الاسبوع الماضي برعايه سعوديه امريكيه
الاشتباكات العنيفه بين قوات الجيش والدعم
السريع في مناطقها بالخرطوم لم تتوقف
وتركزت في مناطق من بينها حي المعموره وحي
الرياض وحي جبرا جنوب العاصمه الاقتتال
العنيف ادى الارتفاع عدد القتلى الى 822
شخص وفقا نقابه اطباء السودان كما اوضحت
النقابه في بيان لها ان عدد الاصابات بلغت
3215 اصابه في الخرطوم وفي الولايات
اقتصاديا اصبح الخيوله نادره في البنوك
التي تعرض او البنوك التي تعرض اغلبها
للنهب لم تفتح ابوابها منذ بدء الحرب
منتصف ابريل الماضي فيما سجلت اسعار
الاسعار وارتفاع عن حادا وصلاه الى اربعه
اضعاف بالنسبه للمواد الغذائيه وعشرين ضعف
بالنسبه للوقود انسانيا الان الوضع يسير
من سيء الى اسوا حيث اعلنت وكاله الامم
المتحده للاجئين عن فرار نحو 200 الف شخص
من السودان منذ بدايه هذا الصراع كما
اشارت الامم المتحده الى بطء استجابه
المانحين في التعامل مع حاله الطوارئ في
السودان ورغبتها في اطلاق مناشده جديده
[موسيقى]
نناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من القاهره
شريف محمد عثمان الامين السياسي لحزب
المؤتمر السوداني وعضو المكتب التنفيذي
لقوى الحريه والتغيير المجلس المركزي اهلا
بك من الرياض محمود لعوته الصحفي السوداني
اهلا بكم ضيوفي الكرام اسمحوا لي ان ابدا
من القاهره معك استاذ شريف استاذ شريف بعد
شهر من الاقتتال الداخلي في السودان اسمح
لنا ان نفهم باكثر وضوح اسباب عدم توقف
الاقتتال هل هو في عدم القدره على ايجاد
خطه حقيقيه لتقريب وجهات النظر اليه
حقيقيه ام بانه ليست هناك اراده ليست هناك
اراده في داخل السوداني للامتثال للالتزام
لايجاد حل حقيقي لهذه الازمه
اولا مساء الخير عليكم ضيفك الكريم وكل
المتابعين المتابعين الكرام حقيقه نحن
الان امضينا 30 يوما وبدانا في الشهر
الثاني
منذ اندلاع الحرب في الخامس عشر من ابريل
الماضي ومن الواضح ان العسكريين لا زالوا
مصرين على ان يتخذوا ذات المسار الخاطئ
المسار الخاطئ الذي اتخذوه هو مسار
المواجهه المسلحه فيما بينهم والقوات
المسلحه وقوات الدعم السريعه هذا القرار
بدا ان هو غرار خاطئ وغير حكيم وغير محمود
العواقب هم يستمرون في ذات الفيزات الخطا
واستمرار هذا هذا الامر هناك جوانب كارثيه
كبيره على على السودان وعلى السوداني
ذكرتهم في تقريركم تدهور على المستوى بتاع
الوضع الانساني في المشاكل الاقتصاديه
وحركه النزوح واللجوء الكبيره في السودان
باستمرار هذا الوضع يعني تفاقم هذه هذه
الازمه واضافه اليها عظمات جديده تتجدد
بالنزاعات الاجتماعيه تابعنا ما حدث خلال
الايام الماضيه في
الاوضاع الى ولكن افهم من حضرتك سيد شريف
بانه الاراده هي التي لا تتوف لدى الطرفين
صحيح
بالتاكيد ان الاراده الاراده السياسيه غير
غير متوفره بشكل كافي لمعالجه هذه الازمه
والاستمرار في هذا في هذا المسار هو ما
يهدد استقرار السودان وسلامه السودانيين
عليه بشكل دائم ضل طالما طالما ناشدنا
القوات المسلحه
بان يستجيبوا عبر طاوله الحوار الدائره
الان في مدينه جده بالمملكه العربيه
السعوديه برعايه امريكيه سعوديه وشركاء
اقليميين ودوليين يدعمون هذه المبادره بل
يستجيبوا الى رغبات السودانيين كل هذه
الازمات الطريقه الوحيد لحلها هو طاوله
الحوار السياسي وليس فوهه فوهه البنات
ولكن
نشرك معنا كذلك ضيفنا من الرياض استاذ
محمود ان كنت تتفق مع ضيفي بان الاراده
مفقوده لدى الطرفين لماذا الذهاب الى جده
لماذا القبول بهذه المبادره
طيب بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
وطبعا
فعلا انا اتفق معه في مساله انه الاراده
مفقوده بدليل انه يعني ذهباء الى ساحه
الحرب في البدايه هم يعني بالرغم حتى اذا
لم نحدد الان منى المخطئ ومن الذي بدا
الحرب فانا اعتقد هم اللذان بداان بالحرب
ومد ومدد يعني ساحات الحرب وانا اعتقد انه
يعني الوضع على على الارض يختلف عن
المفاوضات يعني قد يكون للطرفان
يعني اهداف دفينه بالنسبه للذهاب الى جده
خوفا من اي ضغوط خارجيه او عقوبات يعني
بدا لهم ان يمتسلان الى الجلوس في
المفاوضات وطبعا الطرفان اذا لم يغير
تفكيرهما حقيقه
لن نشهد اي التزام الذي كتب على الورق
وانا اعتقد انه
بهذه هي ذاهبه في الاطاله كما ذكرت يعني
قبل كده مديره الاستخبارات الامريكيه انه
الحرب سوف تكون امادها طويل لانه الطرفان
لا يستطيعان ان يحققان النصر يعني سريع من
اجل حسم المعركه بدليل انه يا اختي الان
المعركه في البدايه كانت منحصره في
المنشات السياديه في القصر في القياده
العامه في الاذاعه الان امتدت يعني الى
الاحياء السكنيه وتتغير خريطه الحرب من
يوم الى اخر يعني واعتقد انه يعني القوات
الدعم السريع حاولت يعني ان تستفز او يعني
تستنزف الجيش السوداني الذي يقوم
بمعاركه وفق خطط تنظيميه مرتبه اعتباره
انه هو جيش نظامي وبالتالي نحن الان يعني
دعينا مما يحدث الان في الميدان الان
اصبحت التداعيات كثيره يعني اخرجت الحرب
او ابرتت هذه الحج الحرب
اشياء سلبيه على المجتمع السوداني ولكن
لدي نقطه واحده يعني واحده لابد ان نفهمها
جميعا العسكر الان ليست لكن اذا دينا تحدث
هنالك انقسامات يعني حاده بين السياسيين
في السودان يعني انا بعرف انه في التاريخ
الطويل للعالم وللدول انه لما يكون اي شعب
في حرب لا بد ان تتحد الجبهه الداخليه
فمشكلتنا الان هنالك خلاف سياسي اعمق من
الخلافه العسكري
استاذ محمود قد يقول لك بعضهم باننا قصص
السياسي في السودان ليس بالجديد حتى قبل
انطلاع هذه الاشتباكات حتى الحريه
والتغيير انقسموا على بعضهم البعض هناك من
ذهب
قدمه بحثات مع الجيش وهناك من وافق على
الاتفاق الايطالي وهناك مره واعتبر بان
الجانب المقابل خائ هكذا وصفه بعد ما كان
دعيني دعيني اعلق على نعم الانقسام موجود
ولكن الان اصبع اصبح الشده حده وانقساما
يعني يعني دخل الناس في في في في في في في
خلافات عميقه لا تساعد يعني في فريق بين
الحرب والسلم يعني احنا لو اختلفنا في
السلم لا توجد مشكله لكن ان نختلف في
الحرب اعتقد هذه المشكله الاكبر يعني لن
نستطيع ان نوحد الجبهه الداخليه من اجل ان
نصل الى حل وقرار يجعلنا ان يعني نحاول ان
نعيد البلاد الى وضعها السابق او وضعها
القديم لكن يعني
الصورتين مختلفتان نختلف في الحق هنالك
حوار هنالك نقاش هنالك تصريحات اما ان
نختلف في في في ساعه الحرب ونريد ان نوقف
الحرب انا اعتقد هذه مساله صعبه
طيب استاذ شريف يقول البعض ب ان في لغه
الحرب حتى وان كانت هناك طاوله مفاوضات
ولكن تبقى الاشتباكات على الارض هي بوصله
هذه المفاوضات هذه المحادثات بمعنى من
يمسك الارض يعلي سقف مطالبه على طاوله
المفاوضات وبالتالي هل يمكن لهذه المعادله
ان تكون موجوده حقيقه في جده هل تاملون
شيء حقيقي من محادثات جده
اولا حتى القضايا حتى القضايا الخلافيه
التي كانت هي اسباب في اندلاع هذه الحرب
حسب الخطاب السياسي للطرفين اعتقد ان ما
قبل الحرب كان القوه المدنيه والدعم
السريع والقوات المسلحه وصلوا الى نقطه من
التوافق حول درجه الى درجه كبيره من
القضايا الخلافيه حول اغرار قائد الدعم
سريع وقوات الدعم السريع بضروره دمجها
داخل القوات المسلحه ومراحل الدمج وتلك
الورقه التي وقعت ما بين الاطراف الثلاثه
باسم اسس وبعدها الاصلاح الامني والعسكري
اعتقد ان ان الاسباب ان الاسباب التي قادت
الى الى هذه الحرب ليست هي كفيله او ليست
هذه الاسباب بذات بذات بالضروره ان تعود
الى هذه الى هذه الحرب والخلافات كانت
محدوده وبسيطه ومن الممكن حلها عبر طاوره
الحوار السياسي الاستمرار في الحرب عبر
عبر الوضع الحالي في في العاصمه الخرطوم
وفي مدن اخرى اعتقد انه لن يحل كثير من
القضايا وانها ستعود الاطراف يوما معي الى
زاد طاوله التفاوض او كما يجلسون الان في
مدينه جده وربما هنا توقع ان اذا المجتمع
المدني السوداني انا لا وفق ضيف الكلمه ان
هناك انغام عميق داخل القوى المدنيه
بالعكس انا اعتقد ان القوه المدنيه
والسياسيه الان في السودان الى حد ما هي
الى اغرب درجات التوافق حتى
المجموعه التي كانت على خلاف مع الحريه
والتغيير العمليه سلميه لغايه ابراهيم حتى
هذه الاطراف هي رافضه لهذه الحرب في نقطه
هذه نقطه ايجابيه سياسي ما بين هذه
الاطراف فانا اعتقد ان القوه المدنيه
القوه المدنيه الاكثر صغلا في في السودان
هي رافضه لهذه الحرب ومتوحده حول هذا
الموقف وداعيه لمعالجه هذه الخلافات عبر
طاوله الحوار السياسي مجموعه محدوده وهي
تنتمي الى نظام النظام البايت هي تدعم هذه
الحرب وايضا مجموعه تدعم الدعم السريع
واخرى تدعم القوات المسلحه لكن القوه
الرئيسيه المدنيه في السودان هي متخذه
الموقف الصحيحه الداعي لايقاف هذه الحرب
والعوده لطاوله المفاوضات علينا
امر اخر هي رساله ورساله مهمه
القوات المسلحه في الدعم السريع لم تنتهي
حرب في تاريخ العالم ولا في تاريخ السودان
عبر فوات البنادق كل القضايا تنتهي عبر حل
سياسي المزوليه الاخلاقيه تجاه هذا الشعب
الذي عانى مرارا وتكرارا منذ ثوره ديسمبر
المجيده في العام 2019 من اخطاء ارتكبها
العسكريين العسكريين في القوات المسلحه
والعسكريين في الدعم السريع استمرارهم في
ارتكاب هذه الاخطاء في حق هذا الشعب
بالتاكيد هذا الشعب لن يغفر لهم ولن
يسامحهم طيب قلت يعني استذكرت مبدا مهم
تقول بانه مقالات كل الحروب هي طويله
المفاوضات وهذا فعلا شاهدناه يعني عبر
التاريخ وهنا سؤال استاذ محمود ضيفي يقول
بانه لن يكون هناك او مستبعد ان يكون هناك
حلول
للاسباب التي اندلعت على اسره هذه الحرب
وبالتالي سيصعب ايجاد حل توافقه في هذا
الموضوع
ضيفي يقول بانه الاسباب تسمعني الان
نعم طيب ممتاز طيف يقول بان الاسباب التي
اندلعت على اثرى هذه الحرب نتحدث عن
المشاكل بين الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع
الاسباب لم تحل بعد ليست هناك حلول لهذه
المشاكل التي اندلعت على اثر الحرب فكيف
ستكون هذه المفاوضات سريعه وقادره على ان
تنتج خطه معينه للتقريب بين وجهات النظر
هل تتفق ام لا مع هكذا طرح
لا يعني ممكن قد تتفق نوعا ما معه في
ما ذهب اليه ولكن يا اختي العزيزه دعونا
نرجع ل 2019 الثوره ثوره شعب من الذي
واستطاعت قوى الحريه والتغيير ان تقود
الشارع لهذا التغيير الكبير ولكن بكل اسف
فشلت ان ان تقيم يعني او تدير يعني دولاب
دوله بسبب انا اعتقد وهذا رايي يعني بحسب
التاريخ يعني نظرا لوجود فراغ سياسي لو ما
وجود فراغ سياسي لا لا لم يعني لم يتدخل
العسكر بهذه القوه يعني لماذا يعني لماذا
يعني اعطي للعسكر القدم المعلا في
المفاوضات او في الاتفاق الايطالي لماذا
تواجه الدعم السريع وقوات الشعب المسلحه
اين المدنيين اين السياسيين يعني السودان
شهد ثورتين شعبيتين عاديتين في 64 و85
وكان المسار السياسي يعني يعني مشى بطريقه
سهله ولكن يا اخي الوضع اختلف الان هنالك
توجد قوات حركات مسلحه توجد قوات دعم سريع
هنا تغيرت الخريطه السياسيه فمن الصعب ان
يعني ان يسير الاتفاق السياسي بالطريقه
التي ذكرتها لانه هنالك يعني اشياء غريبه
على المشهد السوداني لم نشهدها بصورتين
السابقتين فبالتالي وكان يعني
الصوت الحركات المسلحه الدعم السريعه
للقوات المسلحه اقوى من صوت القوى
السياسيه وبالتالي فشلت القوه السياسيه
لتسهيل حكومه انتقاليه
ان توخذ السودان من هذه المشاكل
وتنقذه من المعارك التي تشهدها السودان
تماما الخاص بهذا الملف يعني حضرتك ختمت
قراءتك بلومك للحريه وتغيير وكل قوى
السياسيه ربما سنتابع هذا الموضوع وليس
القوه السياسيين الموجودين الان الساحه
السياديه يعود لهم اللوم في مساله انه
تاخر السودان ودخوله في رحاب لن يشهدها من
قبل وضحت الفكره على كل سنبقى في متابعه
هذا انا مندهش لو في دقيقه واحده في دقيقه
واحده
يطلق يطلق العسكريون الرصاص
وقذائف من الارض ومن الجو وتتحمل
المسؤوليه القوى المدنيه من عم نفذ انغلاق
25 اكتوبر هو المؤسسه العسكريه والمؤسسه
الدعم السريع انا اعتقد ان هذا تحميل غير
صحيح الاخطاء دائما طيله الفكره من 2019
وحتى الان ظل يرتكبها العسكري مشتركون اذا
اتفقوا ونفذوا الانقلاب واذا اختلفوا
وصلوا الى هذه الدرجه وهي درجه الحرب
اعتقد ان تحميل القوه المدنيه هذه
المزوليه هذا غير صحيح وانما يتحمل كافه
المزوليه من 2019
العسكريه
هذه المشكله القوه المدنيه ظلت تعمل
طيب وضحت فكره حضرتك استاذ شريف ووضحت
كذلك فكره حضرتك استاذ محمود هذا الموضوع
على فكره يتحمل اسئله اخرى ونقاشات اخرى
ولكن سنلتقي في حلقه اخرى او تشكركم جزيل
الشكر على المشاركه وطرح هذه الاراء بكل
شفافيه من القاهره شريف محمد عثمان الامين
السياسي لحزب المؤتمر السوداني وعضو
المكتب التنفيذي لقوى الحريه وتغيير
المجلس المركزي وشكر كذلك الحظر بتاعك من
الرياض محمود لعوده صحفي السوداني شكرا
لكما
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات